gone too soon but not forgotten these
beloved actors may have tragically
passed away but their famous faces will
light up the screen one more time in
2024 2023 has seen some particularly
stunning losses in Show Business from
friend star Matthew Perry to Brooklyn 99
favorite Andre Brower to Albert
Dumbledore himself Michael gamban but
the most shocking loss may be that of
promising young actor Angus Cloud yeah 1
Point turned around and they had the
guns pointed at me I'm like oh oh known
for his work on the hit HBO series
Euphoria Cloud passed away unexpectedly
at the age of 25 the actor who played
fesco a drug dealer with a heart of gold
was declared dead after being found in
his California home it was later
revealed that the actor had suffered an
overdose of Narcotics immediately wishes
of love and grief poured in from
Hollywood and Cloud's coars especially
the young cast who worked alongside the
performer on Euphoria before his death
Cloud star was on the rise and as a
result he signed on to multiple projects
that will now feature postumus
performances he already appeared in the
2023 Thriller your lucky day which
received a theatrical release in
November and he's got two things in the
works for 2024 fans of the late actor
will be able to catch him in the horror
flick Freaky Tales alongside Pedro
Pascal and Ben Mendelson as well as an
entitled Universal Monsters movie
featuring Melissa Barrera and Jan Carlo
Esposito fans of Ray Stevenson likely
remember his recent turn in the hit Star
Wars series Ahsoka making the news of
his passing all the more tragic
Stevenson was an accomplished actor who
starred on huge shows like Dexter Rome
and black saes appeared in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as volag in the first
three Thor films and popped up in 2022
is universally beloved tulugu film RR in
which he portrays a brutal British
imperialist sadly Stevenson passed away
in May of this year while working on a
project in isia an Italian island he was
58 years old technically Stevenson's
first postumus performance came in
Ahsoka which pays tribute to the late
actor but he still has one project
upcoming in 2024 Stevenson replaced the
SCC actor Kevin spacy in the Hungarian
action film 1242 Gateway to the West a
drama about to pre managing to stop an
invasion by Mongols when it is released
it will Mark Stevenson's final
performance film and television fans are
definitely familiar with Lance reck who
was one of the best parts of about a
million different projects we
implemented Casual Friday where
employees can wear jeans once a month
well that was a catastrophic mistake
whether people know him from Oz lost the
wire Fringe or even the cult comedy
favorite corporate reic was an
incredible character actor
with an enormous number of credits to
his name sadly Rik passed away from
heart disease on March 17th at the age
of 60 at his California home co-stars
paid tribute to rik's memory including
his John Wick co-stars Ian McShan and
Keanu Reeves Rance is a was is a
very beautiful person special artist
it's appropriate that John Wick chapter
4 was one of reck's first postumus roles
as a spin-off movie set in the same
universe will also feature a performance
from him some of reck's other postumus
releases in 2023 included the remake of
White Men Can't Jump the cane Mutiny
Court Marshal barsh Legacy and Percy
Jackson and the Olympians audiences can
see his final turn of Chiron the
concierge of the New York City
Continental Hotel when the John Wick
spin-off film ballerina hits theaters in